as summer begins the guests arrive
so hurry back well sit down join us it's
me adorable even the thought of her
makes my heart race no no don't be shy
he's a celebrity but he has a simple
soul forestry Goran he's so famous he
looked young he is young and
accomplished don't remind me
the stage is set hello who is that that
you were talking to Lida yes for a
little family drama we see Nina where to
the lake with Boris
it's not often I have the occasion to me
young interesting women what does it
feel like to be famous Martha why is my
son so depressed
he's heartsick what's that supposed to
be
[Music]
such a face to marvelous voice you must
go on the stage I am the you your happy
please be generous let me go
what are you that infatuated with her
why do you always wear black I'm in
mourning for my life
[Music]
I'm the reason for your misery these
past 20 years I've only been miserable
the past ten
I'm just a woman like any other this
your chance to be a woman unlike any
other
remember all the left and the noise
and the love-affairs so many little
bears
The Seagull I am going to tear this love
out of my heart how are you gonna do
that
I'll get married
[Music]
you